[Music]
Yeah.
student.
Yeah. Yeah.
forch.
Okay.
Doctor, the brother's name is Fajar. He
is a student and uh he almost became
mortad or probably became a mortad and
uh because he is disheartened that there
was a d a Muslim famous Di who
mistreated him uh for quite some time.
So he would like to know what is your
response?
Panggal terrorists.
>> Yeah.
>> So when he was a Muslim, he was always
labeled and called as a terrorist. So he
was hurt.
>> Asked a question that he was a Muslim.
He became a mortad means he left the
dean because there was a very famous D
and he used to bully him and he used to
call him a terrorist.
My respond to that question brother is
that suppose you're working in a
company.
You're working in a company. You have
the big boss, the CEO. Then you have
CFO, CEO, and one manager on a good
post. You are a clerk.
And that manager,
he illreats you.
He illreats you.
And that manager, he calls you a thief.
And
you
do not work for that company.
You get salary but you say because this
manager is not treating me well I will
not work for the I'll take the salary
but
I will not work for the company I'll not
come to school sorry I'll not come to
office
>> I will not obey the rules of the company
because this manager is telling lies but
I'll take their salary every day every
month
every month you're taking salary but
because the manager treats you, you are
not following the rules of the company,
you're not doing the job that you should
do. You're a clerk, you have to deliver
the message. Are you right or wrong? But
you're taking the salary.
Is it right or is it wrong?
>> Baba, Dr. Zaka,
>> now the point speaker is working
correctly.
>> Sorry.
>> Now the point speaker is working
correctly.
>> Sorry.
Say the right reason. Don't say the
wrong. Say you were busy doing something
else. No problem.
>> Sorry, doctor. Yes.
CFO, CEO,
director, manager.
Okay. manager.
Okay.
Rules
follow rules.
It's wrong.
>> It's wrong. Now, Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala, Almighty God has given you life.
Allah has given you all these things in
the world. He's given you health. He's
given you house. He's given you clothes.
Even the water you drink is from Allah.
Even the air you breathe is from Allah.
Do you thank Allah for the air? Do you
thank Allah for the water you get?
You cannot say just because of him. He
abused me. He cheated me. He bullied me.
He called me a terrorist. Now I will not
worship Allah. I will not follow his
instruction. Is it correct?
Okay.
[Music]
But not all. He says he should but he
didn't. Like in the company the boss is
there he's giving you salary. If the
manager is no you should complain
the manager to the boss
you cannot say I will not follow the
rules and regulation of the company when
you're getting salary every month. So
similarly if that d was wrong he called
you a terrorist. Are you a terrorist?
>> No.
>> Then what? So why should you feel bad?
If you are not a terrorist, you should
tell him that Allah will punish you for
calling me a terrorist when I'm not a
terrorist. Right or wrong?
Who will Allah support you or him?
>> Should I translate?
>> Yeah, translate to
while I'm talking someone volunteer can
translate. That's better.
>> Zamil, can you translate
>> please go ahead. If one die very famous,
let him be any famous. Is he Allah?
>> No.
>> Yes or no?
>> No. No. Is that Allah?
Is that Allah?
>> Translate brother. What? Translate
please. Zate
papa
boss.
Boss
complains
[Applause]
terrorist
terrorist.
complainish.
Can he comment doctor? Yes.
for
Islam.
Okay. Say translate. What he's saying?
What he's saying doctor that these
incidents where he was bullied and some
people labeled him as terrorist. This
incident uh caused him to be to to get
into depression and he almost committed
suicide. However, his parents were not
understanding and they were forcing him
to continue to pray and uh and so on
rather than helping him out in the
situation. So he is questioning is he on
the true path. He has been praying dha
tajjud and so on and he has been asking
help but his parents are only
emphasizing that he should pray.
If your parents have asked you to pray
because you are depressed, they may not
be doctors. I am a medical doctor. That
is the best solution. The best treatment
for depression is prayer. I gave a talk
4 days before in solo in surah karta.
Salah the programming towards
righteousness. The best treatment for
depression is salah.
Now if you don't offer salah correctly
you will not get cured. Your parent may
not be medical doctors. They may not be
dy. They may be good practicing Muslim.
They might have forced you. Okay good.
But if they were good D they would have
told you what is the solution.
If you have kushu in salah it will solve
your problem. But to get kushu is not
easy. So if you pray, if you don't pay
correctly, you will not get cured. I
give a full talk on that 4 days before
you can see that video. So if your
parents forced you to pray, they were
right. Okay? How you force is important.
Convincing you is better, coaxing is
better rather than you know using the
cane or something. So if they forced
you, it's good. And if you were bullied
by someone, the best treatment for
depression is salah. So what they told
is that but you should pray salah with
Allah says in the Quran in surah chapter
number 23 verse number one and two
you the moment the believer will always
be successful those who pray with
you understand so what your parents
should have done should have taught you
how to get kushu
or maybe if you see my video said salah
programming towards righteousness
inshallah maybe you'll have more kushu
in your salah you understand
so the main problem was that you should
have prayed correct with koshu
if you pray with kushu correctly that is
one of the best treatment for depression
and you should understand what you read
in your salah brother do you understand
Arabic
>> um little bit
>> little bit yeah
>> khal
Yeah, I some little understand.
>> Do you understand what you pray in the
salah?
>> Yeah, little.
>> How much percentage? Little
>> actually 7%.
>> How much percentage?
>> Seven.
>> 7%.
>> Seven. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, 7% is very little.
>> Very little. My advice to you is when
you read your salah whatever you read
you should memorize the meaning by heart
of surah fatya of the suras that you
read and when you memorize you recollect
the meaning and you concentrate on the
meaning the more you concentrate your
mind will not divert the more you
concentrate the more you'll understand
Islam and more you'll follow Islam and
you'll be on the straight path see my
full video cassette on salah the
programming to righteousness but
according to me what that I did is
wrong. If what you're speaking is
correct, if what you're saying is
correct, I don't know who that guy is.
Whatever he did, if you are saying is
correct, he's at fault. But because of
his fault, why should you suffer?
If he made a mistake, you go into
depression. Who's going in los you?
Who's to blame? He's to blame. But even
you are to blame. Why did you get
depressed?
But the problem is if someone is
bullying you, you should know how to not
get bullied.
You should have very well reported him
to some other Muslim organization. Did
you do that?
Did you do that? Yes or no?
>> No.
>> Did you go to any other who who is a big
organization and tell him this person is
bullying me, is calling me terrorist.
Did you do that?
He didn't go to seek help. Uh but
that is the truth.
>> So the problems whether you are to blame
but now now you okay you're depressed
yet?
>> Yeah. Now you are depressed or are you
okay normal?
Now are you depressed or are you normal?
>> He says he's still in depress.
>> Still depressed.
>> No. No. Now.
>> Yeah.
>> Just now also.
>> Huh?
What's your depression?
Depressing.
Now who's depressing you now? right now.
>> Are you normal now?
>> No.
>> What's your problem?
>> Now who's bullying you? I cannot see
anyone bullying you.
Now what excuse you have?
Now what excuse you have for not
believing in Allah? Now okay made a
mistake. You didn't complain. Now what's
the problem? Is the D around you know
yet?
Is the D coming after you now?
>> No. So now what is the problem? Do you
believe there's one God?
>> Sure.
>> Do you believe Prophet Muhammad is a
messenger of God?
>> Yeah.
>> Are you a Muslim?
>> Yes.
>> So why you saying I become a murad?
That means you are causing problem for
yourself. You are a bigger enemy of your
own self than the D. Do you understand?
You have become a bigger enemy of
yourself.
Who is who is a bigger sinner or a
terrorist?
He feels he doesn't know but he feels it
must be mortad because he doesn't go. So
he gave you small problem you made
bigger problem. Who's to blame you?
Correct. So my request to you is now you
believe there's one god. You said in
public that you're a mort. You have to
rectify it immediately. If something
happens to you then gone direct hell.
Do you believe there's one god?
Yeah.
>> Do you believe Prophet Muhammad is the
messenger?
>> Yeah.
>> Do you want to say the shada again?
Do you want to become a Muslim?
>> He still have some thing to ask.
>> What What is preventing you from
becoming a Muslim now?
Then
>> he feels lonely and when he prays he has
no hushu
>> brother that is afterwards
>> when a student takes admission in
nursery ABCD does he know logarithms
does he know medical science no he takes
admission to take admission you have to
believe in two things only. There is one
Allah and Muhammad is a messenger. That
will come afterwards.
So do you want to become a Muslim now or
not is my question.
Uh
the person who took sh before does he
he's he not learned praying also yet.
>> He becomes a Muslim and then he learns
praying. Yeah. So if you're a
non-Muslim, how will you
>> have kushu in the salah?
>> Do you understand? If you'd say you're a
mortad, how will you have kushu? To have
kushu, first you have to become a
Muslim. Do you understand?
So when you're saying you're a mortad,
how will you have kushu?
So first you have to rectify your
mistake. What is your mistake? Someone
bullied you. He made a mistake. You dug
your own grave. Do you understand?
You are digging your own grave.
>> First you have to rectify by believing
there's one God. Believing Prophet
Muhammad is a messenger. Become a Muslim
and start one by one
trying to solve your problem. Do you
understand?
Brother, do you want to read the shada?
Do you want to become a Muslim back?
>> Muslim.
Yes.
>> I think the people who are translated as
volunteers, they're not doing a good
job.
>> Change the change the people of
volunteers. They're not doing good job.
Okay. You want to be a Muslim. Do you
believe there's one God?
>> Yeah. Do you believe Prophet Muhammad is
the messenger of God?
>> Yeah.
>> Is anyone forcing you to be a Muslim?
>> Say translation.
>> No one forcing him.
>> Tomorrow you'll say, "Oh, Dr. Akina came
and forced me to become a Muslim." Okay.
Am I forcing you to be a Muslim?
Islam.
No.
>> Are you doing it out of your own free
will?
Yeah.
>> Okay. I'll repeat. I'll say in Arabic
and we repeat it.
Allah
[Music]
illallahu
>> I bear witness saying Abu Sharis
I bear witness
>> I bear witness
>> that there is no god
>> deadness nor a god
>> but Allah
>> but Allah And prophet Muhammad
>> And prophet Muhammad
>> is the messenger
>> is a messenger
>> and servant
>> of Allah
>> of Allah.
>> Mashallah you have become Muslim now.
Don't call yourself mortas. Okay.
>> Uh
if he ask your permission can he learn
more about Islam? He wants to know.
>> Sure. I will ask the local organization.
Even Donditan Donditan has an
organization for mala forwards. Okay.
Now you are Muslim then Buddha back to
Muslim and there will surely be
organizations in Milan. We will give you
the address. If you can give your name
and the phone number to the volunteer he
will contact you and inshallah he will
see to that he'll give you support. Any
other buddhi comes you contact. He's a
bigger.
>> Thanks so very much.
>> Okay. Most welcome.